Fox NFL Sunday host as a new book he's
worked on for two years losing isn't
everything the untold stories and hidden
lessons behind the toughest losses in
sports history now available in
bookstores and online some of the and
sometimes losing is more interesting
than winning you know I think so and
then you've been in this business like I
have for a long time and we see people
win and we know what happened to them in
general you know they get to go to
Disneyland they get to do the
commercials and those kinds of things
but you find out people say you learn
more from losing that is true but also
what happens these people because at
least my approach with the book was
almost as much psychological as it was
about what happened in the moment and
how'd you blow this player how did you
come up short John van de Velde those
kinds of things how it affected them and
their families and their history and the
people around them because everybody in
this book their legacy is they lost you
know john van de Velde blue believe the
British Open Calvin Schiraldi lost game
six and seven you know Mary Decker fell
at the Olympics Pete Carroll lost in the
super bowl in the play the people can't
believe you know those kinds of things
that becomes their legacy that people
talk about year in and year out is any
who was reluctant to talk that did do it
yeah um Pete Carroll want to talk about
that call at the goal line no yeah he
did he did he was open about you know I
think one of the things is in Craig Ehlo
you have him or Jordan hits the shot on
craig and craig thing was you know that
he didn't deal with it and wound up
years later having to go to drug rehab
that he directly says was his response
to not having confronted his legacy was
that everybody everywhere he went that
he said for for the next ten years
people said you're that guy that's on
the poster that Jordan hit the shot over
and he immediately after the shot he
said they didn't talk about in the
locker room cuz you remember that was
the end of the game ello it scored 24
points in that game including the bucket
that put Cleveland up by one with three
seconds left in the Jordan has a shot
over him he said his wife didn't talk
his family didn't talk everybody left
him alone so he buried it and all these
years later wound up getting hooked on
oxycodone I went to drug rehab first day
there one of the counselors just walking
around cuz hey aren't you that guy and
he's like look I'm
I'm here to get help yeah so he had to
deal with it like that i think calvin
schiraldi's an interesting one because
everybody blames Buckner for that ball
going through his legs in Game six but
if you go back to the game Boston had a
one run lead in the clicked what would
have been the clinching game in the
eighth inning sure aldi blew that out of
the bullpen they had a two-run lead of
the 10th sure all he gets the first two
outs and then gives up three straight
hits to blow that lead so he loses Game
six putting everything into motion for
buckner comes in and game 7 33 time as
seventh inning gives up a home run der a
night loses game 6 and 7 and he admitted
that mentally he never got over that
moment he only pitched the majors four
more years retired at the agent I know
he's blamed though 486 that's right then
that to me was the interesting thing why
does history look at some people and
blame them for losing and other people
who are really responsible for the
losses skate and he said in his mind he
obviously was responsible because he
blew Game six and seven but the play
wasn't shown over and over and over and
over like the buckler thing is and that
bothered him as much because in his mind
in his words you know Buckner took a lot
of bleep that he probably shouldn't have
but he buried that he didn't deal with
it and finally in 2013 27 years after
1986 his wife told look we're getting a
divorce unless you go to therapy cuz
you're not the same guy that I married
that was in the minors because he said
in his defense he put up walls that was
the only way he know how to deal with it
his father later committed suicide not
because of that but he said he saw the
way his father handled things and what
it led to and he did not want to be that
guy and with his wife coming to him so
almost 30 years later he's still dealing
with it it's amazing what it was the
story that you didn't know now you
interviewed everybody i think yet and
you're talking about calvin schiraldi
Craig Ehlo Bill Curry and Lou Michaels
that was the bill named Joe Namath upset
Aaron krickstein facing Jimmy Connors at
the US Open Ron Washington the Rangers
manager who was fired by they lost the
World Series he was fired had the
cocaine issue as well read gettys who
played for phi slamma jamma al downing
who gave up 7 15 to hank aaron two of
the guys on the Kentucky team that
didn't guard christian Laettner Mary
Decker Rodney Harrison the helmet catch
your guy
yes everson walls who was supposed to be
trying to guard Dwight Clark right who
had the catch against the Cowboys dan
jansen the speed skater and and then
Pete Carroll from a 2015 well who told
the story that made you go I'm glad I
did this you know I think the Schiraldi
thing for one just to find out that
here's a guy who's carrying this burden
that most of us don't even look at as a
burden for 30 years and two things I
think Rodney Harrison his thing was
interesting because we know him he's in
every time you see this David Tyree
catch yeah he's there trying to defend
it he said physically he thought he
knocked the ball away you know he
thought he swatted away and he heard
Steve Smith go get off of him good catch
and he's like good catch what and he
looked and he saw he had the ball but
that play bothered him because he's used
to being the guy who makes the play what
bothered him even more though was the
touchdown pass he says Dean pees the
defensive coordinator called a blitz on
the play he looks over after they get
lined up he's in charge of the defense
sees five foot nine Ellis Hobbs lined up
against six foot five lexical burrows
and goes I know right away it's a
touchdown so I say let's call off the
blitz Junior Seau who was on that team
had not won a Super Bowl said no let's
run it and he goes no let's call it off
and Jim goes no let's run it and he said
out of his admiration for junior because
when he came in as a rookie a
fifth-round pick in San Diego jr. took
him under his wing he ran the Blitz when
he knew that he should not have wound up
being a touchdown he said he didn't even
turn around soon as the ball was thrown
because he knew and he admitted that had
that been any other player tedy bruschi
or anybody else that he would have
called off the blitz he would have said
no this is the right thing to do but he
admired junior so much and wanted to
help him try to get a ring that he let
him go on the Blitz and that bonded be
the game-winning touchdown we're talking
to Curt Menefee Fox NFL Sunday host the
book is losing isn't everything the
untold stories and hidden lessons behind
the toughest losses in sports history
available in bookstores you go back to
Craig Ehlo could not have played better
defense on Jordan on that jumper it's
just Craig goes up stays up Jordan
continues to keep going up and then
Craig comes down Jordan still up and
then hits the jumper Rodney couldn't
have played a better right defensive
position on you know David Tyree yeah
and that's why that cat's bothers him
simply because he said he's used to
making plays and he didn't but
touchdown bothers him even more because
that was a mental error and that was
something he could control you talk
about the Ehlo situation with Jordan and
that goes back to he says they had not
double-team Cleveland hadn't anybody all
year long they get in the timeout and
Laney Wilkins goes we're going to
double-team him so they go back on the
court and they're discussing how do we
do this where do we stand at the fun
part the guys didn't know so there was
some question in their mind before the
ball was even then bounded then
physically he's trying to fly by Jordan
he says Jordan hung up there forever he
hits the shot so you get some insight
like that you know one of the things Ron
Washington talked about was the David
Freese hit you know they're mean there
were one strike away from winning the
world series and that and again I think
it comes off I don't want it to sound
like they're blaming people but he says
Nelson Cruz they had him in no doubles
and he and Gary Pettis no playing so
there's no doubling so there's no
doubles right exactly and so Ron and
Gary Pettis were in the dugout and they
didn't notice that just slowly that
Nelson had creeped in and he took a few
steps and so he was out of position and
so when that ball went over his head he
froze also as soon as the ball was hit
but had he been in the right position
that ball is probably caught the game is
over the Rangers win the World Series
and I got it wasn't blaming him he was
saying you know look this thing's has
just happened they happen in a game and
you're not paying attention to
everything and the rest is history are
the Cubs a better story now that they
won or when they didn't win you know I
think they were my wife's from chicago
so i have to be careful you know I i
think the Cubs though it's almost like
Boston the Red Sox were a fascinating
story when they didn't win as soon as
they won when it was a great story then
then when a second is like yeah okay and
then they went to Thursday yeah okay you
know now they're just another good team
yeah and I think that that's the
jeopardy that the Cubs have I'm sure
they'll take it but you look at that
team everybody's 23 24 25 they're
probably going to win another or two and
I think they're less fascinating they're
less lovable from a national standpoint
now that they won one maybe Cleveland
will become that T you also guess host
Don the Bruce Springsteen channel so you
need you out of it an hour playlist of
Springsteen songs now are you always the
one black guy at the Springsteen yes yes
that's me
that sounds like a song by vibrate yeah
or Donald Trump yeah you never know um
now so when you're putting that list
together mm-hmm in at any part of your
mind do you think Springsteen could hear
this yes you do I'll be Hamid Khan it's
in this to the back and you're going
he's probably not really sitting in the
car driving around listening to his own
channel you know I mean that's a little
bit more ego that I think he's got but
you mean like me watching reruns to this
show like when i get home in the brakes
aren't you can check out the last
segment you see how you did so no have
you met Springsteen yeah a couple times
actually so you know I originally knew
Terry McGovern who if you're a
Springsteen fan Terry song was done for
him after Terry passed away could have
not had been a nicer man on this planet
but Terry was his road manager so I met
Bruce actually in Spain once in
Barcelona with Terry and then I know his
current road manager whose name I
probably won't throw out there since he
still alive and I don't want people
bugging him but I've met Bruce with him
as well and I also know his head of
security who was a really good friend
and comes out and sees it at Fox and so
I know enough people around him that
I've been introduced to him a couple of
times yes your favorite Springsteen song
my favorite Springsteen song is the live
version of the ghost of old Tom Joad
because I'm a big Tom Morello fan and
the guitar riff he does on that come
unbelievable come fan too yeah exactly
it met him a couple weeks ago actually
at a sushi restaurant in the valley so
well see you only work on Sunday you got
all this time I mean I got too many damn
gun I'm not this is who I hang with Kurt
well you know what but you've got a more
you're a man of the people I don't want
to be a man of the people I'm hanging
with Springsteen and Tom Morello yeah
last night you know I ran into last
night I don't know you're Dave Matthews
guy yeah Carter Beauford together yeah
ran into him last night you know it's
like this is this is the trouble I role
in that guy's a cool cat he is he really
is I met him a couple years ago through
Howie Long with Howie at an event for
the Boys and Girls Club that how he does
every year back in Charlottesville and
so he ran in each other last night big
hug and it was he was celebrating his
birthday so good is it this could get
well I i went to see them in Hartford
and I I met Dave on a movie set with
Sandler and so I went backstage to meet
him before
the concert and he said let me take you
to introduce you to somebody who
actually knows what you do for a living
because Dave doesn't know anything about
sports okay nothing so we go down the
hall and all of a sudden we take a left
and Carters in there and he goes uh
Carter do you know who this is and then
he goes of course and then Dave goes I
don't why don't you guys talk I so she
left me in there when Carter went back
to his basically drop you off in Carter
with computers and all it was he did
yeah we did oh good luck with the book
thank you so much thanks for having me
that you know it's one of the things I
don't know how much time we have here I
don't want to take this run with it too
long but everybody always talks about
how cool you are and what a good guy you
are I'm suppose your son's birthday this
weekend too by the way oh the 29 Jack
yeah another mutual friend see I know
people that know people how so that's
how it but anyway I'm supposed to say hi
for that but one of the things is is
that a lot of people and I'm 100-percent
serious about this I listen to you guys
as I Drive into the gym and believe it
not to go to the gym in LA every morning
and so I listen to you guys but one of
the things that I respect about you so
much in this business because you know
how he makes the joke you can't have two
quarterbacks in the same room a lot of
people think you can't have two guys who
are show host in the same room because
the ego is getting away and you're never
like that I mean you're just you're not
just a man of the people you're a real
guy and you also know that your audience
is smart enough it's not like they go
well there's Curt Menefee who's on Fox
and I'm on NBC and my gosh I'm gonna
switch channels or whatever people oh I
don't they take in everything and my
point is that doesn't bother you know
there are people in this business that
refuse to be seen in the same place that
somebody on another network is and
you're not like that that's one of the
things I respect and I love about you
and I appreciate you having me well it's
I want the competition but it doesn't
mean that I don't embrace the
competition or if somebody says ways a
better host than you I mean that's it
that doesn't even factor in the same way
there's like some people like but now on
some people like strawberry you know
everybody's got different tastes but I
don't think you have to be an enemy just
because you work it yo one works welcome
the other words a Pepsi when we were at
the mothership though yeah we felt there
we it was us against the world
absolutely well and it goes the other
way and that's kind of part of the point
I'm making in that you know there are
people that are the people that are over
there fight I think most that most of
the people that are on air you run into
them in a private setting or whatever
everybody's cool but when it comes to
even like publicity for the book of all
know you can't be with him or you can't
have him on your show you can't do this
and it's just like okay you know the
reason why I when I started this the one
thing I said his management cannot be
involved mmm and I said if you promise
and my boss has never been involved
Chris Chris long at directv has never
gotten involved he just said you have it
on I hired you and that's because i said
i want to have ESPN people on or fox or
whoever it is I don't care what the
competition is if the story is there to
be told I'm doing it for the audience
right that's the most important person
here is sitting in the car right now
listening to you talk about your book
that's who we serve so they don't care
about the different networks and cuz
they know it I mean it's not like they
don't know what they know everybody
works different places and as you said
if it's interesting it's interesting but
thank you but don't stab me in the back
and try to take my job on football night
in America well I've got a pretty good
when the Fox NFL Sunday though so you
know oh so you think that's better than
football night in America uh well if you
want to get down to it i would i would
keep the greek gig that i have over the
gig that you have this is just me for me
personally what everybody people some
people like vanilla and I like getting
up early on Sunday mornings and living
in Los Angeles and doing multiple games
a week that's just me what if i gave you
football night in america in Los Angeles
and Fox NFL Sunday in New York you know
what if you throw in the Olympics oh
yeah that's part of it okay okay well we
may have a deal though we may have to
talk oh no we're just training yeah I
thought you were making me an offer no I
don't want I don't want to go out there
and get up early I'm telling you how
great Los Angeles is and you can work I
was just I just told you it was a great
gig you should take it tell Terry I said
a low because Terry won't come on the
show cuz we had a little exchange where
he talked about using steroids back in
the 70s to come back from an injury not
steroids to get bigger and right and I
and I felt bad about that cuz I think
he's great and then you know he had a
problem with that I'm like I'm not
outting you for using steroids you said
it and then I wanted to know about that
right okay I'll make sure I thought I'm
sure I just made it worse
yeah I guess what's going on what do you
say what do you say Kurt yeah what are
you saying the book is losing isn't
everything Curt Menefee Fox NFL Sunday
host probably the next host of football
night in America the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience